This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Behind every night spent making the kids' lunches, there's a lot of suspense. Will they finally eat the veggies? Will the pastos survive the first bite? Will the lunchbox come home empty, half full, or come home at all?
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真实。在每个为孩子们准备午餐的夜晚背后，都充满了悬念。他们最终会吃蔬菜吗？意大利面能撑过第一口吗？午餐盒回家时是空的、半满的，还是根本没带回来？
And will you finish episode 8 before you're done slicing the cucumbers? Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with Craved Netflix and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on Internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.za for details and to check availability. Bell. Connection is everything. Lisa, tell them about our new show. We have a new podcast. It's called Don't Lie to Me. I'm Lexi Youanu. We're two best friends, 22 years apart, but so close at heart. And I'm Lisa Di Giulio, the old one, which means we have wildly different references, occasionally different opinions.
在你切黄瓜的时候，你能听完第8集吗？购买Bell纯光纤互联网，每月94美元起，附赠Netflix和Disney Plus。互联网服务价格保证两年，需签订两年合约并使用自动付款优惠。访问bell.ca了解详情并查询覆盖范围。Bell。连接就是一切。Lisa，告诉他们我们的新节目。我们有一个新播客。它叫《别对我撒谎》（Don't Lie to Me）。我是Lexi Youanu。我们是两个最好的朋友，相差22岁，但心意相通。我是Lisa Di Giulio，年纪大的那个，这意味着我们有截然不同的参考系，偶尔也有不同的观点。
And at this point in my 50s, I've lived it all. Now in my 30s, being the founder of new shoes, good taste is my business. Listen on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hi, this is Kylie Breakman. Angel Geratana. Jeremy Colhain. Patrick McDonald. And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists on Artists Podcast. The improvised character comedy podcast where each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft.
在50多岁的这个阶段，我经历了一切。现在我30多岁，作为新鞋的创始人，好品味是我的事业。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。嗨，我是Kylie Breakman。Angel Geratana。Jeremy Colhain。Patrick McDonald。我们是《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》（Artists on Artists on Artists on Artists）播客的主持人。这是一个即兴角色喜剧播客，每周都有一个新的艺术家小组讨论他们的手艺。
Join us for a panel of Eurovision participants. And we do a little Halloween sometimes. Does the Pope dress up? He winks on Halloween. He gets right up next to the microphone. I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other You never seen Italy so quiet As when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween
加入我们，参加一个由欧洲歌唱大赛参赛者组成的小组讨论。我们有时也会过万圣节。教皇会打扮吗？他在万圣节眨眼。他直接凑到麦克风前。我听说你几乎能听到睫毛撞击的声音。你从未见过意大利像教皇在万圣节眨眼时那样安静。
Listen to Artists on Artists on Artists Every Thursday on the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts I'm Lacey Mosley, author, actor, stand-up comedian, creator and host of Scam Goddess Podcast The True Crime Comedy Podcasts all about robbery, fraud And those who practice it Each week I bring on an amazing guest
每周四在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》。我是Lacey Mosley，作家、演员、单口喜剧演员，也是《骗子女神》（Scam Goddess）播客的创作者和主持人。这是一档关于抢劫、欺诈以及那些行骗之人的真实犯罪喜剧播客。每周我都会请来一位了不起的嘉宾。
Ooh, I scammed them What? I can talk to you for an hour. You're a generational yapper like me. That's why I had to make yapping a job. And now you can catch full episodes of my show on YouTube. Start listening to Scam Goddess on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. So by age 11 or so, at least 70% have a phone.
噢，我骗了他们。什么？我可以和你聊一个小时。你和我一样是个滔滔不绝的人。这就是为什么我必须把聊天变成一份工作。现在你可以在YouTube上观看我节目的完整剧集。开始在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《骗子女神》。所以到了11岁左右，至少70%的孩子有手机。
I'm Dr. Joy, and this is therapy for black girls. We spend our surviving middle school run getting into what's happening inside your kids' brain, the group chats, and their friendships, and what you can do about it. it. Your child is not doing this on purpose. That's the kind of perspective we've been pulling from the psychologists and psychiatrists who studied this for a living. Listen to therapy for black girls on the iHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spake and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
我是Joy博士，这是《黑人女孩心理治疗》（Therapy for Black Girls）。我们花时间在“生存中学生活”中深入探讨孩子大脑内部发生的事情、群聊以及他们的友谊，以及你能为此做些什么。你的孩子不是故意这样做的。这就是我们从研究这一领域的心理学家和精神科医生那里获得的视角。在iHeart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《黑人女孩心理治疗》。大家好。我是Jemma Spake，欢迎回到《你20多岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个我们讨论20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。
Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It's so great to have you here back for another mini bonus episode of the show, which is part of our debunking psychology series. If you are new to this series twice a month, we take a common psychological theory, an idea, a term, a concept that has been, I would say, a little bit misconstrued by the internet or by online chatter. And we basically go about setting the record straight. These are concepts and ideas that might not be able to, you know, be part of a one hour long episode, but are still really, really crucial and really, really important, I at least think, to know and to know the details of correctly. So far we have done myths about the brain.
大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来参加节目的另一个迷你奖励剧集，这是我们“揭秘心理学”系列的一部分。如果你是这个系列的新听众，我们每月两次选取一个常见的心理学理论、观点、术语或概念，这些内容可能被互联网或在线讨论稍微误解了。我们基本上会去澄清事实。这些概念和想法可能无法放入一个小时长的剧集中，但我认为了解并正确掌握细节仍然非常、非常关键。到目前为止，我们已经讨论了关于大脑的误区。
We've done the theories in life of Sigmund Freud. What else? Stockholm Syndrome, personality tests. narcissism, and today we are going to do the Stanford Prison Experiment. This is our first time during the series, zeroing in on one specific study, and I think we chose a really, really good one. There have been countless movies, countless TV shows, countless documentaries about this experiment. It is in practically every single psychology textbook under the sun. But what actually happened. How many of us truly know the details of this study, how it came to be, how it came to
我们讨论了西格蒙德·弗洛伊德的生活理论。还有什么？斯德哥尔摩综合症、人格测试、自恋，今天我们要讨论斯坦福监狱实验。这是我们系列中第一次聚焦于一个特定的研究，我认为我们选择了一个非常、非常好的案例。关于这个实验，有无数的电影、无数的电视节目、无数的纪录片。它几乎出现在每一本心理学教科书中。但实际上发生了什么？我们中有多少人真正了解这项研究的细节，它是如何开始的，它是如何
end, and the legacy. You may have also heard in the news that Netflix is planning on doing a new version of the experiment as a reality TV show. And I thought, you know what? If they're thinking of doing that, it might be time to go back and examine why that's probably not a good idea. no hate to Netflix, of course, you can't bite the hand that feeds you and all that. But I just felt like a psychological history lesson seemed rather timely. So without further ado, let's get into the Stanford Prison Experiment in all of its glory. So to start at the very, very beginning, after World War II, there was this weird period of time where psychologists just seem to have a lot of permission to just do the most outrageous
结束的，以及它的遗产。你可能也在新闻中听说Netflix计划将该实验制作成真人秀节目。我想，你知道吗？如果他们打算这样做，也许是时候回顾并审视为什么这可能不是一个好主意了。当然，不是讨厌Netflix，你不能咬喂养你的手，诸如此类。但我只是觉得心理学历史课似乎相当及时。所以事不宜迟，让我们深入了解斯坦福监狱实验及其全貌。首先，从最开始说起，二战后，有一段奇怪的时期，心理学家似乎有很大的许可去做最离谱的
experiments if it meant that we could understand better how Nazism happened, how this level of authoritarianism and violence and genocide occurred. People really wanted to know. We wanted answers about evil. We wanted to know how evil happened and how ordinary people ends up doing things that we always thought they wouldn't do. Essentially, people wanted to know is this capacity to do awful things in all of us, or were these just really awful people? So the Stanford Prison Experiment was one kind of such study that was trying to figure that out,
实验，如果这意味着我们能更好地理解纳粹主义是如何发生的，这种程度的威权主义、暴力和种族灭绝是如何发生的。人们真的很想知道。我们想要关于邪恶的答案。我们想知道邪恶是如何发生的，以及普通人是如何最终做出我们一直认为他们不会做的事情的。本质上，人们想知道这种做可怕事情的能力是否在我们所有人身上，还是这些人只是非常可怕的人？所以斯坦福监狱实验就是试图弄清楚这一点的一种研究，
and it was led by a man named Philip Zimbardo. He was a social psychologist at Stanford, and he was really focused in a broader sense on ideas of persuasion, de-individuation, the psychology of the mob mentality, the psychology of evil. Basically, you just wanted to understand, as everybody did at that time, how do good people do bad things, or were they even good people to begin with? So this particular study took place in August 1971, and it was funded by the US Offel of Naval Research. So, the military. And what they were really interested in was anti-sophiles.
它由一个名叫菲利普·津巴多（Philip Zimbardo）的人领导。他是斯坦福大学的社会心理学家，他更广泛地关注说服、去个性化、暴民心理学、邪恶心理学等概念。基本上，他只是想了解，正如当时每个人都想了解的那样，好人是如何做坏事的，或者他们一开始就是好人吗？所以这项特定的研究发生在1971年8月，由美国海军研究办公室资助。所以，是军方。他们真正感兴趣的是反社会行为，
social behavior, particularly in military prisons and in authority structures. According to the Stanford Prison Experiment Archive, the original purpose of the study was to understand how norms, roles, labels, uniforms, social expectations, create a prison environment, even when everything should be going well. Basically, what makes a prison? Is it just four walls? or is it what is expected of people within it? Like I said, this experiment was very, very of its time.
特别是在军事监狱和权威结构中。根据斯坦福监狱实验档案，该研究的最初目的是了解规范、角色、标签、制服、社会期望如何创造一个监狱环境，即使一切都应该进展顺利。基本上，是什么造就了监狱？仅仅是四堵墙吗？还是人们在其中的期望？就像我说的，这个实验非常、非常具有时代特征。
Around the same time, there was another very famous set of studies by Stanley Milgram where they were like cool. I can't remember what they were exactly called, but they were basically studies on obedience. And in these studies, very ordinary people had very shockingly administered what they believed were dangerous electric shocks to random people, because an authority figure had told them to.
大约在同一时间，斯坦利·米尔格拉姆（Stanley Milgram）进行了另一组非常著名的研究，他们当时觉得很酷。我不记得它们具体叫什么了，但它们基本上是关于服从的研究。在这些研究中，非常普通的人在权威人物的指示下，令人震惊地对随机的人实施了他们认为是危险的电击。
And the psychology community was like, that can't possibly be right. How could this happen? We want to test this in some different environments. So Zimbardo, the creator or the founder of the Stanford Prison Experiment, wanted to go above and beyond. And he wanted to really look at what happens when one group is given power and another group is stripped of it. And then both groups are placed into an institution,
心理学界当时觉得，这不可能正确。这怎么可能发生？我们想在不同的环境中测试这一点。所以津巴多，斯坦福监狱实验的创造者或发起人，想要更进一步。他想真正看看当一组人被赋予权力而另一组人被剥夺权力时会发生什么。然后两组人都被安置在一个机构中，
designed around control. So this is how they got participants to take place in this study. Because I think if I saw a newspaper ad that said, we want to put you in a simulated prison environment for, I don't know how long, two weeks and see what happens to you. And also you might be a prisoner, you might be a guard. We can't really tell you at this stage. I would probably be like, I'm not that desperate for money.
设计围绕着控制。这就是他们让参与者参加这项研究的方式。因为我想如果我看到一份报纸广告说，我们想把你放在一个模拟监狱环境中，持续，我不知道多久，两周，看看你会发生什么。而且你可能是囚犯，也可能是狱警。我们在这个阶段无法真正告诉你。我可能会说，我还没那么缺钱。
I'm okay. But a lot of people, a lot of men in the kind of Palo Alto community were interested. They advertised in this paper, the two papers, the Stanford Daily and the Palo Alto Times. And they said, all right, we're going to give you $15 a day, which is about $120 a day now, if you come and participate in this study. And they targeted specifically male college students. More than 70 people applied. They then interviewed those 70 people and they excluded people and they excluded people and
我很好。但很多人，帕洛阿尔托社区的很多男人都很感兴趣。他们在报纸上刊登了广告，两份报纸，《斯坦福日报》和《帕洛阿尔托时报》。他们说，好吧，如果你来参加这项研究，我们将每天给你15美元，相当于现在的每天120美元。他们专门针对男性大学生。超过70人申请。然后他们面试了那70人，并排除了那些人，排除了那些人，
the basis of medical problems, psychological difficulties, criminal records, all of that stuff. And what was left were 24 young men, mostly healthy, mostly middle class, all Ivy League college students. And then they randomly assigned them to either be a prisoner or a prison guard. The random assignment in this situation was very, very critical. Zimbardo's argument was that the two groups were not fundamentally different to begin with. These people were, were all quite similar. These people weren't particularly sadistic. One group wasn't particularly dominant. The other group wasn't particularly submissive. They were randomly assigned. But he believed that when they were put into a specific role, that they would inhabit that role.
基于医疗问题、心理困难、犯罪记录等等。剩下的是24名年轻男性，大多健康，大多是中产阶级，都是常春藤盟校的大学生。然后他们随机分配他们成为囚犯或狱警。在这种情况下，随机分配非常、非常关键。津巴多的论点是，这两组人一开始并没有根本的不同。这些人，都很相似。这些人并不是特别残忍。一组人并不是特别占主导地位。另一组人并不是特别顺从。他们是随机分配的。但他相信，当他们被置于一个特定的角色中时，他们会沉浸在那个角色中。
And when specifically they were put into a position of authority, they would gladly take that authority regardless of their initial kind of temperament. So this mock prison, where was it built? It wasn't out of prison. It was in the Stanford Psychology Department. And what they did was they closed off the lab rooms. They basically closed off a whole corridor of the building. And they made the rooms on that corridor cells. And then the corridor was the prison yard. They even had a small closet. They called it the hole. It was solitary confinement. There were no windows. There were no clocks. And the researchers used cameras and they used intercoms to kind of monitor what was happening in side. The other thing they did, which I was like, that seems like, Zimbardo really, he really
特别是当他们被置于权威位置时，无论他们最初的气质如何，他们都会欣然接受那种权威。那么这个模拟监狱建在哪里？它不是在监狱里。它是在斯坦福心理学系。他们所做的是关闭了实验室房间。他们基本上关闭了整栋大楼的一条走廊。他们把走廊上的房间变成了牢房。然后走廊就是监狱操场。他们甚至有一个小壁橱。他们称之为“洞”。那是单独监禁。没有窗户。没有时钟。研究人员使用摄像头和对讲机来监控里面发生的事情。他们做的另一件事，我觉得，津巴多真的，他真的
wanted to make this seem very real for the participants, was that they literally arrested them. So these people were not, again, they weren't criminals. They were random college students who had agreed and were getting paid to do the study. And they were kind of told, like, you just show up at this time and then we'll get started. And for the people who he designed prisoners, he kind of tricked them. What he actually did was he sent out a number of police cars. And he kind of got the local police force in on the study. And he was like, I want you to arrest these people. And then I want you to read them their rights.
想让这看起来对参与者非常真实，就是他们真的逮捕了他们。所以这些人不是，再说一次，他们不是罪犯。他们是随机的大学生，他们同意并获得报酬来做这项研究。他们被告知，就像，你只要在那个时间出现，然后我们就开始。对于那些他设计为囚犯的人，他有点欺骗了他们。他实际上做的是派出了几辆警车。他让当地警察参与了这项研究。他说，我希望你们逮捕这些人。然后我希望你们宣读他们的权利。
I want you to search them. I want you to take them to the police station. I want you to blindfold them. And then we'll take it from here. And the prisoners slash the participants had no idea that was happening. Then they got to the experiment, they got to the fake prism. They were searched again, they were stripped, they were sprayed with water, they were given smocks to wear without underwear, they were assigned identification numbers, they were made
我希望你们搜查他们。我希望你们把他们带到警察局。我希望你们蒙住他们的眼睛。然后我们从这里接手。囚犯/参与者根本不知道发生了什么。然后他们到达了实验地点，到达了假监狱。他们再次被搜查，被剥光衣服，被喷水，被给予没有内衣的罩衫穿，他们被分配了识别号码，他们被要求
to wear a stocking cap over their hair, so it kind of made it look like they had a shaved head. He really was, he was really getting into this simulation of the prison. He really wanted it to feel like you were stripped of your identity, you were being humiliated, you were being controlled, and you were ultimately powerless. I want to really remind you of this quickly. This study was approved by an ethics board. He went to an ethics board and said, hey guys, here's my plan.
戴上丝袜帽遮住头发，所以看起来就像剃了光头一样。他真的，他真的沉浸在这个监狱模拟中。他真的希望它感觉就像你被剥夺了身份，你正在被羞辱，你正在被控制，你最终是无能为力的。我想快速提醒你这一点。这项研究是由伦理委员会批准的。他去了一个伦理委员会说，嘿伙计们，这是我的计划。
What do you think? And they were like, yeah, all right, sounds fine. And that was only like 50 odd years ago. There are people who are involved in this study who are very much still alive. one of them is ironically a very well-known prison reform advocate now and he was in his 20s when this took place so whilst all of that was happening with the prisoners the guards they wore uniforms they carry batons they wore mirrored sunglasses they worked in shifts so the prisoners had to be their day and night the guards got to leave they rotated in and out and they were essentially instructed to like keep peace keep order they are in charge of this fake
你们觉得怎么样？他们说，是的，好吧，听起来不错。那只是大约50年前的事了。参与这项研究的人中，有些人现在还活着。其中一个人讽刺地现在是一位非常著名的监狱改革倡导者，当这件事发生时，他才20多岁。所以当所有这些事情发生在囚犯身上时，狱警们穿着制服，带着警棍，戴着镜面太阳镜，他们轮班工作，所以囚犯必须日夜待在那里，狱警可以离开，他们轮流进出，他们基本上被指示要维持和平，维持秩序，他们负责这个虚假的
institution. The simulation, let's just say, it became very intense, very quickly. The participants were very distressed. Well, they displayed a lot of symptoms of distress. That's important to say displayed, because we're going to get into that a little bit later. They were obviously very anxious. Some of them even appeared to have emotional breakdowns. And the guards became really, really punitive. They really did start to humiliate the participants. They just started to disrupt and deprive them of sleep. They became very insistent on very arbitrary rules and it quickly became apparent that it was a bit of a mess. Like this was really going the way that they expected, but a lot faster than they expected it to. The craziest part of this, this study was supposed to,
机构。模拟，我们只能说，变得非常激烈，非常迅速。参与者非常痛苦。好吧，他们表现出了很多痛苦的症状。说“表现出”很重要，因为我们稍后会讨论这一点。他们显然非常焦虑。有些人甚至似乎精神崩溃了。狱警变得非常、非常具有惩罚性。他们确实开始羞辱参与者。他们开始扰乱并剥夺他们的睡眠。他们变得非常坚持一些非常武断的规则，很快就显而易见，这有点混乱。就像这确实朝着他们预期的方向发展，但比他们预期的要快得多。这最疯狂的部分是，这项研究本应
last two weeks. These people were paid for 14 days. It ended after just six. When the experiment is reported, often it's that the guards became so abusive and the prisoners became so distressed that Zimbardo, he just put a stop to the experiment. That is only partly true. Zimbardo himself had actually taken on the role of a prison superintendent. He was not just observing from the outside at a detached kind of distance. He wasn't just watching through the cameras. He had actually positioned himself within the institution that he had created. How the experiment ended in actual fact was that this woman, her name was Christina Maslach. She was a PhD at the time. Later, she became Zimbardo's wife, which is another thing. But she was visiting him at work, I guess. And she was
持续两周。这些人获得了14天的报酬。它只持续了六天就结束了。当实验被报道时，通常说的是狱警变得如此虐待，囚犯变得如此痛苦，以至于津巴多，他只是停止了实验。这只是部分真实。津巴多本人实际上已经担任了监狱主管的角色。他不仅仅是从外部以一种超然的距离观察。他不仅仅是通过摄像头观看。他实际上已经把自己定位在他创造的机构内。实验实际上是如何结束的，是这个女人，她的名字叫克里斯蒂娜·马斯拉奇（Christina Maslach）。她当时是博士。后来，她成了津巴多的妻子，这是另一回事。但她当时在工作时拜访他，我想。而且她
visiting the experiment and she walked in and she was so disturbed by what she saw that in the moment she challenged Embardo directly and was essentially like, you don't know what you have created. This is a terrible idea. This is completely unethical. You need to stop. And she kind of cut through a lot of the male ego as like this voice of reason. This is where the Stanford Prison Experiment really gets his notoriety as because, being more than just a study and actually about the ethics of research itself, right? It is so
正在参观实验，她走了进去，她对所见所闻感到非常不安，以至于在那一刻她直接挑战了津巴多，基本上是说，你不知道你创造了什么。这是一个糟糕的主意。这完全是不道德的。你需要停止。她有点像理性的声音，打破了许多男性自负。这就是斯坦福监狱实验真正获得恶名的原因，因为它不仅仅是一项研究，实际上是关于研究本身的伦理，对吧？它是如此
shocking that this was allowed to happen. I think that's why people are so fascinated by it. One of the biggest ethical criticisms of this study is that participants were exposed to significant psychological harm. A lot of the participants became very distressed, despondent, scared, and yeah, they technically agreed to be part of the study. They were paid. But would they have agreed if they knew the full extent of it. What they realized afterwards when people were analyzing and reading into the study protocol was that Zimbardo didn't really properly inform them. He didn't really tell them the extent to what they were going to endure.
令人震惊，这竟然被允许发生。我认为这就是为什么人们对它如此着迷。这项研究最大的伦理批评之一是参与者遭受了重大的心理伤害。许多参与者变得非常痛苦、沮丧、害怕，是的，他们技术上同意参加这项研究。他们获得了报酬。但如果他们知道全部程度，他们会同意吗？当人们分析和阅读研究方案时，他们意识到津巴多并没有真正适当地告知他们。他并没有真正告诉他们他们将要忍受的程度。
And so he actually didn't obtain informed consent. And that is one of the most critical things you need to obtain, you need to have, before you conduct any kind of psychological experimentation. There was also that huge conflict in roles. As I mentioned, Zimbardo was both the lead researcher and he himself was playing a role in the fake prison. He was the prison superintendent, meaning that the person responsible for protecting the participants was also invested in maintaining the prison simulation and also was very, very susceptible to getting carried away and experiencing the same kind of behavioral changes that he was trying to. to observe in other people as a neutral party, as a neutral researcher. So it really, really blurt the lines between observation and participation. I don't know whether he included this in
所以他实际上没有获得知情同意。这是你在进行任何心理学实验之前需要获得、需要拥有的最关键的事情之一。角色之间也存在巨大的冲突。正如我提到的，津巴多既是首席研究员，他自己也在假监狱中扮演角色。他是监狱主管，这意味着负责保护参与者的人也致力于维持监狱模拟，并且也非常、非常容易被冲昏头脑，经历他试图在其他人身上观察到的那种行为变化，作为一个中立的观察者，作为一个中立的研究员。所以它真的、真的模糊了观察和参与之间的界限。我不知道他是否在
his ethics application. To be honest, again, I don't know how the heck this got approved. But I would assume that that would be a major, major red flag if a researcher is also essentially experimenting on themselves as they experiment on other people. Even afterwards, Zimbardo kind of of never fully took responsibility for what happened. He did become quite a strong research ethics advocate, but kind of in the way of like, look at this. I became such, I was a victim. Like, can you see that if this happened to me, this could happen to anyone? We need people to tell us not to do this stuff. And people are kind of like, I think most people know, most people don't want to play prison with a bunch of people who they have authority over and they don't,
他的伦理申请中包含了这一点。老实说，再说一次，我不知道这到底是怎么被批准的。但我会假设，如果一个研究员在对其他人进行实验的同时，本质上也在对自己进行实验，那将是一个重大、重大的危险信号。即使在事后，津巴多也从未完全为发生的事情承担责任。他确实成为了一个相当坚定的研究伦理倡导者，但有点像那种，看看这个。我成了受害者。你看，如果这发生在我身上，这可能发生在任何人身上。我们需要人们告诉我们不要做这些事情。而人们有点像，我想大多数人都知道，大多数人不想和一群他们拥有权威的人玩监狱游戏，他们不，
you know what I mean? Like I think a lot of people know not to do that and to not give people weapons and to not arrest them in the middle of the night. We don't really need a big higher power body to tell us that. But I guess he said we do. The study was also subject to a few controversies around its method as well. For decades, the Stanford Prison Experiment was treated as this prime example of how people internalize oppressive roles. Anybody could do this. You and me, if we were put in the same position, this would happen to us. Give someone the role of God, they will quickly become a God. They will quickly become cruel. Later, those scholars kind of argued that the interpretation of this was way too simple. Firstly, the
你知道我的意思吗？就像我认为很多人知道不要那样做，不要给人们武器，不要在半夜逮捕他们。我们真的不需要一个大的更高权力机构来告诉我们这一点。但我猜他说我们需要。这项研究也受到了一些关于其方法的争议。几十年来，斯坦福监狱实验被视为人们如何内化压迫性角色的主要例子。任何人都可以做到这一点。你和我，如果我们处于同样的位置，这也会发生在我们身上。给某人上帝的角色，他们很快就会成为上帝。他们很快就会变得残忍。后来，那些学者有点争论说，对这一点的解释太简单了。首先，
the study was done on exclusively Ivy League men who were, let's be real, probably more likely than the average person to be a bit of a rule follower, right? They got into Stanford. There was obviously some kind of rule and some kind of plan and some kind of system that they understood and that they played by. A further 2019 paper that also examined a lot of the deeper archives and interviews claimed that there was also evidence that the researchers, not just Zimbardo, but some of the other researchers who were present, were encouraging a certain kind of behavior. They were trying to create a certain kind of result. And so as a result of that, they got a lot of, like, people did behave with cruelty.
这项研究完全是在常春藤盟校的男性身上进行的，说实话，他们可能比普通人更容易成为规则的追随者，对吧？他们进入了斯坦福。显然有一些规则、一些计划和一些他们理解并遵守的系统。2019年的一篇论文也检查了许多更深层的档案和采访，声称也有证据表明研究人员，不仅仅是津巴多，还有一些在场的其他研究人员，在鼓励某种行为。他们试图创造某种结果。因此，结果是，他们得到了很多，就像，人们确实表现得很残忍。
They did behave sometimes with punitive violence. But were they doing that because that was their natural instinct? or were they doing that because there were these people saying, this is what we expect to see, deliver that. This is what we want you to do. This is what we thought you would happen. And that's not happening so you're disappointing us. Basically, were the expectations of the researchers actually shifting the results?
他们有时确实表现出惩罚性的暴力。但他们这样做是因为那是他们的本能吗？还是他们这样做是因为有这些人说，这就是我们期望看到的，交付它。这就是我们想要你做的。这就是我们认为你会发生的。而那没有发生，所以你让我们失望了。基本上，研究人员的期望是否实际上改变了结果？
If you put somebody in a lab coat in a room who has authority, there was a researcher or a lecturer and you are just a student, are you just going to follow along with what they are saying? because you yourself are worried about some kind of form of punishment. Something else really interesting is also seen in how the participants responded after the study, a few years down the line. And I want to talk about that after this short break. Behind every night spent making the kids' lunches, there's a lot of suspense.
如果你把一个穿白大褂、拥有权威的人放在房间里，有一个研究员或讲师，而你只是一个学生，你会仅仅因为担心某种形式的惩罚而跟随他们所说的话吗？还有一些非常有趣的事情也体现在参与者在研究几年后如何回应。我想在这次短暂的休息后谈谈这一点。在每个为孩子们准备午餐的夜晚背后，都充满了悬念。
Will they finally eat the veggies? Will the pastos survive the first bite? Will the lunchbox come home empty, half full, or come home at all? And will you finish episode 8 before? Or you're done slicing the cucumbers? Get Bell pure fiber internet with craved Netflix and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.ca for details and to check availability.
他们最终会吃蔬菜吗？意大利面能撑过第一口吗？午餐盒回家时是空的、半满的，还是根本没带回来？在你切黄瓜的时候，你能听完第8集吗？购买Bell纯光纤互联网，每月94美元起，附赠Netflix和Disney Plus。互联网服务价格保证两年，需签订两年合约并使用自动付款优惠。访问bell.ca了解详情并查询覆盖范围。
Bell, connection is everything. Lisa, we should tell them about our new show. Oh my God, Lexi. We have a new podcast. It's called Don't Lie to Me. I'm Lexi Youwano. We're two best friends, 22 years apart, but so close at heart. And I'm Lisa DeJulius.
Bell，连接就是一切。Lisa，我们应该告诉他们我们的新节目。天哪，Lexi。我们有一个新播客。它叫《别对我撒谎》。我是Lexi Youwano。我们是两个最好的朋友，相差22岁，但心意相通。我是Lisa DeJulius。
the old one, which means we have wildly different references, occasionally different opinions, and at this point in my 50s, I've lived it all. I'm not going to get anyone fighting. That is wild. I learned that about you today. Now in my 30s, being the founder of new shoes, good taste is my business,
年纪大的那个，这意味着我们有截然不同的参考系，偶尔也有不同的观点，在50多岁的这个阶段，我经历了一切。我不会让任何人打架。那太疯狂了。我今天了解到了关于你的这一点。现在我30多岁，作为新鞋的创始人，好品味是我的事业，
and I've always got something to say. If men were just honest about this, there would be so much more peace in the world. We're going to talk about dating, relationships, beauty, getting older and a little wiser. We're best friends, but we don't always agree. Because you told us how accommodating you are. Obviously, I would do what I think I could do to fight the fight,
我总是有话要说。如果男人对这一点诚实，世界将会更加和平。我们将讨论约会、关系、美容、变老和变得更聪明一点。我们是最好的朋友，但我们并不总是同意。因为你告诉我们你有多么随和。显然，我会做我认为我能做的事情来打这场仗，
but there's only so much fight I can fight. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Liar. Listen on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I don't really care. Hi, this is Kylie Breakman.
但能打的仗只有这么多。别对我撒谎。别对我撒谎。别对我撒谎。别对我撒谎。别对我撒谎。别对我撒谎。骗子。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。我真的不在乎。嗨，我是Kylie Breakman。
Angel Geratana. Bill Hane, Patrick McDonald. And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists Podcast. The Improvised Character Comedy Podcast where each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft. Join us for a panel of wellness influencers. What I try to do is faux journal. I don't know. Have you guys heard of faux journaling?
Angel Geratana。Bill Hane，Patrick McDonald。我们是《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》播客的主持人。这是一个即兴角色喜剧播客，每周都有一个新的艺术家小组讨论他们的手艺。加入我们，参加一个由健康影响者组成的小组讨论。我尝试做的是伪日记。我不知道。你们听说过伪日记吗？
Yeah, it's reading. It's called reading. So we don't like to use that word anymore. Okay. A panel of New Yorker cartoonists. Have you guys done Terry Gross's Peloton class? No. I've been dying.
是的，那是阅读。它叫阅读。所以我们不想再用那个词了。好的。一个由《纽约客》漫画家组成的小组。你们做过Terry Gross的Peloton课程吗？没有。我一直很想做。
I'm so sorry. I'm seeing a reading of Sadako in the Thousand Paper Cranes by Audra McDonald's at the Wonderland Bookstore on 14th. That's crazy. I went to the Wonderland bookstore yesterday and I heard Norah Jones do a reading of Zero Dark 30. No way. You have to come to the last
我很抱歉。我正在14街的仙境书店看Audra McDonald朗读《佐佐子与一千只纸鹤》。那太疯狂了。我昨天去了仙境书店，我听到Norah Jones朗读《猎杀本·拉登》（Zero Dark 30）。不会吧。你必须来最后一家
bookstore though. Kim Cottrell is reading the guitar tabs of yesterday. A panel of Eurovision participants. And we do a little Halloween sometimes. Does the Pope dress up? He winks on Halloween. He right up next to the microphone.
书店。Kim Cottrell正在读《昨日》的吉他谱。一个由欧洲歌唱大赛参赛者组成的小组。我们有时也会过万圣节。教皇会打扮吗？他在万圣节眨眼。他直接凑到麦克风前。
I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween. Listen to artists on artists on artists on artists on artists on the IHeard radio app, Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Lacey Mosley, author, actor, stand-up comedian, creator, and host of Scam Goddess Podcasts, the True Crime Comedy Podcasts all about robbery, fraud, and those who practice it. Each week I bring on incredible guests like Conan O'Brien. Iowa Debrie, Lamorn Morris, and Nicole Byer.
我听说你几乎能听到睫毛撞击的声音。你从未见过意大利像教皇在万圣节眨眼时那样安静。在IHeard radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》。我是Lacey Mosley，作家、演员、单口喜剧演员，也是《骗子女神》播客的创作者和主持人。这是一档关于抢劫、欺诈以及那些行骗之人的真实犯罪喜剧播客。每周我都会请来令人难以置信的嘉宾，比如Conan O'Brien、Iowa Debrie、Lamorn Morris和Nicole Byer。
Ooh, I scammed them. What? I can talk to you for an hour. You're a generational yapper like me. That's why I had to make yapping a job. And the scams run the gamut. I'm talking about scams from the 1800s all the way up to today. I also warn you and keep you safe against scammers.
噢，我骗了他们。什么？我可以和你聊一个小时。你和我一样是个滔滔不绝的人。这就是为什么我必须把聊天变成一份工作。骗局多种多样。我说的是从1800年代一直到今天的骗局。我也警告你，让你免受骗子的伤害。
Call your grandparents. Tell your parents to stop clicking on links, please. And now you can catch full episodes of my show on YouTube. If there's a scam, I'm here to protect you. And I'm also here to laugh with you. So if you like fun, if you like comedy, and you like learning and protecting yourself from criminals, start listening to Scam Goddess on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. By age 11 or so, at least 70% have a phone.
给你的祖父母打电话。告诉你的父母停止点击链接，拜托。现在你可以在YouTube上观看我节目的完整剧集。如果有骗局，我在这里保护你。我也在这里和你一起笑。所以如果你喜欢乐趣，如果你喜欢喜剧，并且你喜欢学习和保护自己免受罪犯的伤害，开始在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听《骗子女神》。到了11岁左右，至少70%的孩子有手机。
Middle school is a different world than the one we grew up in. I'm Dr. Joy, and this is Therapy for Black Girls. We spend real time on it in our surviving middle school run. bringing in a child psychologist and a psychiatrist who's raising two black girls of his own to talk about what's really going on with our kids right now. So it's literally physiological and neurological and psychological and psychological chaos happening all this end up. We got into group chats and gaming, friendships and bullying, and how to tell the difference between healthy monitoring and the kind of surveillance that erodes trust. There's belonging. You could think of belonging as I can be myself and I can still be accepted. and then there's fitting in.
中学是一个与我们成长时期不同的世界。我是Joy博士，这是《黑人女孩心理治疗》。我们花真正的时间在我们的“生存中学生活”中。请来一位儿童心理学家和一位正在抚养两个黑人女孩的精神科医生，谈谈我们的孩子现在到底发生了什么。所以这简直是生理上、神经上、心理上和心理上的混乱。我们深入探讨了群聊和游戏、友谊和欺凌，以及如何区分健康的监控和那种侵蚀信任的监视。有归属感。你可以把归属感看作是我可以做我自己，我仍然可以被接受。然后是融入。
Spitting in says I have to change who I am in order to avoid rejection. Then we turn the conversation toward the fathers, sitting down with therapists Keir Gaines on Black fatherhood and what it means to raise a daughter through this stage. You don't have on shorts, so you can't do flips, you have on the dressy, you can cross your legs. That's the range of this run,
融入说我必须改变我是谁，以避免被拒绝。然后我们将对话转向父亲，与治疗师Keir Gaines坐下来谈论黑人父亲身份，以及在这一阶段抚养女儿意味着什么。你没有穿短裤，所以你不能做后空翻，你穿的是裙子，你可以交叉双腿。这就是这个阶段的范围，
from screen time to identity to the father's doing the work at home. We have to get off her device, but the reality is there's a lot of life out there that we don't want you as your adults in their lives to miss out on. This has been our surviving middle school run. Brought to you by the people who spend their careers thinking about exactly this. I'm Dr. Joy. Listen to Therapy for Black Girls on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
从屏幕时间到身份，再到在家工作的父亲。我们必须让她离开设备，但现实是外面有很多生活，我们不希望你们作为他们生活中的成年人错过。这就是我们的“生存中学生活”。由那些职业生涯中专门思考这一点的人带给你。我是Joy博士。在Iheart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《黑人女孩心理治疗》。
So Zimbardo, after this study came out and after people were a little bit shocked, to say the least, he argued that there was no evidence of long-term harm. He was like, nothing. These guys were fine. They went home. They had some food. They were, they were good. Like, they knew it was an experiment. Everything was happy and all was well. What a lot of people point out is that how would he know? Because something that Zimbardo didn't do was that he didn't properly debrief his participants. The prisoners' accounts post-study actually highlight a really complex mix of, genuine distress and also performed distress that confused them and made them really question what kind of people they were. On one hand, some of the men were truly messed up by the environment.
所以津巴多，在这项研究出来之后，在人们感到有点震惊之后，至少可以说，他争辩说没有长期伤害的证据。他说，什么都没有。这些家伙很好。他们回家了。他们吃了一些食物。他们，他们很好。就像，他们知道这是一个实验。一切都很开心，一切都很好。很多人指出的是，他怎么会知道？因为津巴多没有做的一件事是，他没有适当地对参与者进行汇报。囚犯在研究后的陈述实际上突显了真实的痛苦和表演出的痛苦的复杂混合，这让他们感到困惑，并让他们真正质疑自己是什么样的人。一方面，有些人确实被环境搞砸了。
You know, imagine being stripped of your name, forced into a uniform, and then when you finally look a researcher in the eye and you ask to go home, they tell you no. There was a part of this that was a little bit of a hostage imprisonment situation. And that creates a very, terrifying feeling of helplessness. And for a few of these guys, that anxiety and that resentment lasted for years. They felt like they were genuinely trapped in a lawless society. They felt like I cannot believe that at an institution like Stanford, this was allowed to take place. But on the other hand, some of these men basically said, I was just performing. I was just performing. Really, I didn't feel anything. I was just doing what I was told to do. And people,
你知道，想象一下被剥夺了名字，被迫穿上制服，然后当你最终看着研究员的眼睛并要求回家时，他们告诉你不行。这其中有一部分有点像人质监禁的情况。这创造了一种非常可怕的无助感。对于其中几个人来说，那种焦虑和怨恨持续了多年。他们觉得他们真的被困在一个无法无天的社会里。他们觉得我无法相信在斯坦福这样的机构，这竟然被允许发生。但另一方面，这些人中的一些人基本上说，我只是在表演。我只是在表演。真的，我什么都没感觉到。我只是在做我被告知要做的事情。而人们，
are really torn between whether they are telling the truth or whether they are just saying that because some part of their humanity, their personality, their sense of self was revealed to them and they didn't like it. It's a lot easier to say I was just playing the role that was assigned to me. I knew it was fake the whole time rather than, oh no, like I really fell under the trance and what this revealed about me was something that I didn't really like. So there's an example of this that I think is important. That is the example of this man called Douglas Corpi. So in the original recordings of the study,
真的在他们是否说真话，或者他们只是那样说，因为他们人性、个性、自我意识的某一部分向他们揭示了，而他们不喜欢它之间感到纠结。说“我只是在扮演分配给我的角色”要容易得多。我一直知道它是假的，而不是，噢不，就像我真的陷入了恍惚，这揭示了关于我的一些我并不真正喜欢的东西。所以有一个例子，我认为很重要。那就是这个名叫Douglas Corpi的人的例子。所以在研究的原始录音中，
his reaction was probably one of the most famous. He was captured screaming. He was having an hysterical breakdown on the audio tapes. Those audio tapes went like the equivalent of viral back in 1970. A lot of people heard them. Years later, though, he said, no, I was fine. I wasn't having a psychotic break. I was just playing pretend. He essentially said, you know, I was a college kid. My exams were coming up. I kind of realized that, oh, I probably
他的反应可能是最著名的之一。他被录下尖叫。他在录音带上精神崩溃了。那些录音带在1970年就像病毒一样传播开来。很多人听到了。然而多年后，他说，不，我很好。我没有精神崩溃。我只是在假装。他基本上说，你知道，我是一个大学生。我的考试快到了。我有点意识到，噢，我可能
can't be here for two weeks. I need to study. But because the researchers wouldn't let him leave, he realized his only ticket out was to put on a massive performance. He literally said, like, I just needed to make sure that the clinicians believed that I was going crazy so I could get out of there. That's a tricky thing because that does show what people will do when they are in a situation they don't want to be in. They will perform and act the way that we want them to. But it also kind of undercuts, I don't know, it's complicated because then the fact that he knew he was acting means that we probably know that the guards maybe did also feel and know that they were acting a little bit. So how much of the behavior was real versus performed?
不能在这里待两周。我需要学习。但因为研究人员不让他离开，他意识到他唯一的出路就是进行一场大规模的表演。他字面上说，就像，我只需要确保临床医生相信我快疯了，这样我才能离开那里。这是一件棘手的事情，因为这确实显示了当人们处于他们不想处于的情况时会做什么。他们会表演并按照我们想要他们的方式行事。但这也有点削弱了，我不知道，这很复杂，因为既然他知道他在演戏，这意味着我们可能知道狱警也许也确实感觉到并知道他们也在演戏。那么多少行为是真实的，多少是表演的？
how much of it as well was, again, the social desirability effect. Before and after, I'm acting this way to make somebody happy, i.e. the researchers. And then afterwards, I'm telling a certain narrative of how I felt in the experiment so that I can keep up the facade of the reality I want to believe. That being, no, I didn't go crazy, I'm actually totally fine, or no, I'm not actually evil. I was just performing because it was an experiment. So would we get the same results today? Maybe not. I think that's what everybody is interested in watching when this Netflix series comes out.
其中有多少也是，再次，社会期望效应。之前和之后，我这样做是为了让某人高兴，即研究人员。然后事后，我讲述了一个关于我在实验中感受的特定叙述，这样我就可以维持我想相信的现实的门面。那就是，不，我没有疯，我实际上完全没问题，或者不，我实际上并不邪恶。我只是在表演，因为它是一个实验。那么我们今天会得到同样的结果吗？也许不会。我认为这就是当Netflix系列出来时每个人都感兴趣观看的内容。
Like, these people know they're being filmed. Are we going to see the same reactions? I also think this study, the original, had 24 male college students as a participants. They were the same age. They were, I'm pretty sure all of them or the majority of them were white. They were relatively affluent. And there was no control group. There was no control group. So people say, and I think this is a fair point. We look at the Stanford Prison Experiment. we think it says something deeper about humanity. In some respect, it does, but it really just says something deeper about that part of humanity. One of the big challenges that people bring up is why and how would this study change if women were involved.
这些人知道自己正在被拍摄。我们还会看到同样的反应吗？我还认为这项研究，即最初的研究，有24名男性大学生作为参与者。他们年龄相同。我非常确定他们所有人或绝大多数人都是白人。他们相对富裕。而且没有对照组。没有对照组。所以人们说，我认为这是一个合理的观点。我们审视斯坦福监狱实验，认为它揭示了关于人性的更深层的东西。在某种程度上确实如此，但它实际上只是揭示了人性中那一部分更深层的东西。人们提出的一个重大挑战是，如果女性参与其中，这项研究会为何以及如何改变。
The whole reason the study ended was because a woman walked in and was like, this is ridiculous. This is crazy. Like, what are you doing? So if we were to do a similar study with all women, would we see the same results? If we were to do a similar study with people who weren't in college or people who were older or people who were from different backgrounds, would we see the same things? People have tried and it's been very difficult to replicate the original findings of Zimbardo study, primarily as well because nobody wants us to do that again. So the ethics, hurdles that need to be crossed over are just too high for somebody to do this study exactly as it was done in the past once more. For Zimbardo, the legacy of this study was basically his entire legacy.
这项研究结束的全部原因是一位女性走进来，觉得这太荒谬了。这太疯狂了。就像，你们在做什么？所以，如果我们用全女性参与者进行类似的实验，我们会看到同样的结果吗？如果我们用非大学生、年龄较大或来自不同背景的人进行类似的实验，我们会看到同样的事情吗？人们尝试过，但很难复制津巴多研究的原始发现，主要是因为没人想再做一次。因此，需要跨越的伦理障碍太高，以至于没人能再完全按照过去的方式进行这项研究。对于津巴多来说，这项研究的遗产基本上就是他的全部遗产。
He continued to write about it, he continued to speak about it, he continued to give the study as an example of the widespread availability or presence of evil and institutional behavior. he didn't ever really acknowledge that he had maybe done the wrong thing. He would write these long articles and these long rebuttals that in the end, yes, his experiment may or may not have harmed people, but it was worth it. It was worth it because we learnt so much. It was worth it because that is a study that could never be done again. Nobody would allow it. So thank God we did it at least once and we tried it and we saw what we could find.
他继续撰写关于它的文章，继续谈论它，继续将这项研究作为邪恶和制度化行为广泛存在或表现的一个例子。他从未真正承认自己可能做错了。他会写这些长篇大论和反驳文章，最终结论是，是的，他的实验可能伤害了人，也可能没有，但这是值得的。这是值得的，因为我们学到了很多。这是值得的，因为这是一项永远无法再做的研究。没人会允许。所以感谢上帝，我们至少做了一次，我们尝试了，我们看到了我们能发现什么。
some people have argued that you know maybe he's right maybe a study like that had to be done in order for psychology and in order for these scientific communities to be like we can't just do any experiment we want to do we need to have rules we need to have guidelines you know we needed experiments like this one and like the obedient studies to veer us back onto a safe nice path i don't know i feel like maybe we didn't. But whatever you think of the study, it does have a huge cultural legacy. Firstly, it led to a great deal of prison reform discussions. As I said, one of the men involved is now a huge prison reform advocate, probably because he saw with his own two eyes how toxic this could become. And it massively popularized the concept of situational power and the idea that ordinary people
有些人认为，你知道，也许他是对的，也许必须进行这样的研究，心理学和这些科学界才能意识到我们不能随心所欲地做任何实验，我们需要有规则，我们需要有指导方针。你知道，我们需要像这样的实验和服从研究来引导我们回到一条安全、良好的道路上。我不知道，我觉得也许我们并没有。但无论你怎么看这项研究，它确实有着巨大的文化遗产。首先，它引发了大量的监狱改革讨论。正如我所说，其中一名参与者现在是一位坚定的监狱改革倡导者，这可能是因为他亲眼目睹了这种情况会变得多么有毒。它极大地普及了情境力量的概念，以及普通人
placed in a powerful institution or situation can behave in ways that we never would have predicted. When we think about dictators, billionaires, tech AI geniuses who these days seem like hell bent on destroying the world and being powerful and being important. And, you know, everybody says they were once these nice, innocent kids, they never would have heard of fly. Is this what's happening? Is there a level of power that no human should ever have access to no matter what, because it will turn them into a bit of a beast? Or are some people just born bad? were these people always going to be like that, regardless of the money or the power that they had access to. It's a big debate.
置身于一个强大的机构或情境中，可能会表现出我们从未预料到的行为。当我们想到独裁者、亿万富翁、科技人工智能天才时，他们这些天似乎一心想毁灭世界，变得强大且重要。而且，你知道，每个人都说他们曾经是那些可爱、无辜的孩子，他们连一只苍蝇都不会伤害。这就是正在发生的事情吗？是否存在一种无论如何人类都不应该拥有的权力，因为它会把他们变成野兽？还是有些人天生就是坏的？无论他们是否有机会获得金钱或权力，这些人是否注定会那样？这是一个巨大的争论。
And that's why I think people continue to be fascinated by this study because of what it says about us and the lingering question we all have, which is, what would I have done? What would I have done? Really, if I was in that study, we all think that we'd be able to stand up and say, this is really wrong. Let's stop this right now. We all think that we wouldn't succumb to like the power trip. but I'm sure many of those men thought that as well
这就是为什么我认为人们继续对这项研究着迷，因为它揭示了关于我们自身的信息，以及我们所有人心中挥之不去的疑问，那就是：我会怎么做？我到底会怎么做？如果我真的参与了那项研究，我们都认为自己能够站出来说，这真的错了。让我们现在就停止吧。我们都认为自己不会屈服于那种权力欲望。但我肯定那些男人中也有许多人是这样想的
and a lot of those guys would have thought that never would be me how could Naziism happen how could people do such evil things and then it seems as if they were doing evil things even if they pretend or they say they were acting the situation still created that reaction of needing to act
而且他们中的许多人会认为那绝不会是我，纳粹主义怎么可能发生，人们怎么能做出如此邪恶的事情，然后看起来他们似乎正在做邪恶的事情，即使他们假装或声称他们只是在演戏，情境仍然产生了那种需要行动的反应
personally this might sound controversial but if we could do a way with all of the ethical concerns, I would like to see this study done on women. Really, I would. I think it would have happened very, very differently. It's never going to happen. But if there was another, like, but if they did, I think it would be really interesting to see whether this is, everyone could be, everyone who was in this situation could act this way, or whether it is men specifically of a certain age and a certain demographic who will act this way and of a certain ambition level should I say if we had a bunch of like women or a bunch of people who perhaps
就我个人而言，这听起来可能很有争议，但如果我们能消除所有的伦理顾虑，我希望能看到这项研究在女性身上进行。真的，我很想。我认为结果会非常、非常不同。这永远不会发生。但如果还有另一次，如果他们真的做了，我认为观察这是否是每个人在这种情况下的表现，或者这是否是特定年龄和特定人口统计学特征的男性才会有的行为，以及他们是否有某种程度的野心，这会非常有趣。如果我们有一群女性，或者一群可能
weren't that hell bent on being successful or being a good student like would we see the same thing I don't know I guess we'll never know I would I would love to see it are we watching that Netflix show, if it ever happens very closely because I think, yeah, I think it will, I don't know, I think it will bring about a lot of conclusions that were left open-ended by this study, like the performance element, the social desirability element, and the gendered element as well. That is all I have time for. Thank you for listening. If you liked this debunking psychology episode and you like episodes that have a bit more
并不那么执着于成功或成为好学生的人，我们会看到同样的事情吗？我不知道，我想我们永远不会知道。我很想看到它。如果Netflix的节目真的播出了，我们会非常密切地关注，因为我认为，是的，我认为它会带来许多这项研究留下的悬而未决的结论，比如表演元素、社会期望元素以及性别元素。这就是我所有的时间了。感谢您的收听。如果您喜欢这期心理学揭秘节目，并且您喜欢稍微多一点
history to them, we have a whole Spotify playlist of these kinds of episodes for you binge. There's episodes on personality tests, Freud, Stockholm syndrome, dopamine, narcissism. There's just so much there. Honestly, I always, I get to that, I get to like five and I forget all the other ones we've done. But I will leave a link in the description. I would very much recommend you check it out. Thank you to our researcher Libby for her assistance with this episode. Make sure that you are following us on Instagram at that psychology podcast if you want more content like this. Or you can follow us on Substack. And if you you haven't yet, press subscribe, press follow whatever you are listening. And please leave us a
历史感的节目，我们有一个完整的Spotify播放列表，里面有这类节目供您狂听。有关于人格测试、弗洛伊德、斯德哥尔摩综合症、多巴胺、自恋的节目。那里有太多内容了。老实说，我总是，我听到第五个就忘记了我们做过的所有其他节目。但我会在描述中留下链接。我非常建议您去看看。感谢我们的研究员Libby对本期节目的协助。如果您想要更多这样的内容，请确保在Instagram上关注我们的播客账号@thatpsychologypodcast。或者您可以在Substack上关注我们。如果您还没有，请点击订阅，点击关注，无论您在哪里收听。请给我们留下一个
five-star review if you learn even one thing from today's episode or if you feel cool to do so. And until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Lisa, tell them about our new show. We have a new podcast. It's called Don't Lie to Me. I'm Lexi Youanu. We're two best friends, 22 years apart, but so close at heart. And I'm Lisa DiGulio, the old one, which means we have wildly different references, occasionally different opinions, and at this point in my 50s, I've lived it all. Now in my 30s, being the founder of new shoes, good taste is my business. Listen on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
五星好评，如果您从今天的节目中学到了一点东西，或者如果您觉得这样做很酷。下次见之前，请注意安全，保持善良，善待自己。我们很快就会再聊。Lisa，告诉他们我们的新节目。我们有一个新的播客。它叫《别对我撒谎》。我是Lexi Youanu。我们是两个最好的朋友，相差22岁，但心意相通。我是Lisa DiGulio，年长的那位，这意味着我们有截然不同的参考点，偶尔有不同的观点，而且在我50多岁的时候，我已经经历了一切。现在我30多岁，作为新鞋品牌的创始人，好品味是我的事业。请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。
Hi, this is Kylie Breakman. Angela Geratana. Jeremy Colhane. Patrick McDonald. And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists Podcast. The Improvised Character Comedy Podcasts were each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft. Join us for a panel of Eurovision participants. And we do a little Halloween sometimes.
嗨，我是Kylie Breakman。Angela Geratana。Jeremy Colhane。Patrick McDonald。我们是《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》播客的主持人。这是一个即兴角色喜剧播客，每周都有一个新的艺术家小组讨论他们的手艺。加入我们，参加一个欧洲歌唱大赛参与者的小组讨论。我们有时也会做一点万圣节特别节目。
Does the Pope dress up? He winks on Halloween. He gets right up next to the microphone. I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween. Listen to Artists on Artists on Artists every Thursday on the IHeart Radio app,
教皇会打扮吗？他在万圣节眨眼。他直接凑到麦克风旁边。我听说你几乎能听到睫毛撞击的声音。你从未见过意大利像教皇在万圣节眨眼时那样安静。每周四在IHeart Radio应用程序上收听《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Lacey Mosley, author, actor, stand-up comedian, creator, and host of Scam Goddess Podcasts. The True Crime Comedy Podcasts all about robbery, fraud, and those who practice it. Each week I bring on an amazing guest. Ooh, I scammed them. What? I can talk to you for an hour. You're a generational yapper like me.
Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。我是Lacey Mosley，作家、演员、单口喜剧演员，也是《骗局女神》播客的创作者和主持人。这是一个关于抢劫、欺诈以及那些实践者们的真实犯罪喜剧播客。每周我都会请来一位很棒的嘉宾。噢，我骗了他们。什么？我可以和你聊一个小时。你和我一样是个滔滔不绝的人。
That's why I had to make yapping a job. And now you can catch full episodes of my show on YouTube. Start listening to Scam Goddess on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. So by age 11 or so, at least 70% have a phone. I'm Dr. Joy, and this is Therapy for Black Girls. We spend our surviving middle school run getting into what's happening inside your kids' brain, the group chat, and their friendships, and what you can do about it. Your child is not doing this on purpose.
这就是为什么我必须把滔滔不绝变成一份工作。现在你可以在YouTube上观看我节目的完整剧集。开始在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听《骗局女神》。所以到了11岁左右，至少70%的孩子有手机。我是Joy博士，这是《黑人女孩的治疗》。我们花时间在初中阶段深入探讨孩子大脑中发生了什么、群聊、他们的友谊，以及你能为此做些什么。你的孩子不是故意这样做的。
That's the kind of perspective we've been pulling from the psychologists and psychiatrists who studied this for a living. Listen to Therapy for Black Girls on the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Is there an epidemic against literature? More specifically, Black Literature. I'm Jack Quist-Peace Thomas, and on this season of the Black Litts podcast, we're outside asking why.
这就是我们从以此为生的心理学家和精神科医生那里汲取的观点。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《黑人女孩的治疗》。是否存在针对文学的流行病？更具体地说，是针对黑人文学。我是Jack Quist-Peace Thomas，在这一季的《黑人文学》播客中，我们走出去询问原因。
They don't want a whole bunch of little Ella Bakers, Michael Maxes and Martin with the Kings running around. And when you look at a lot of different cultures, they're like, we need to know where you came from. And considering this is Black Reading Month, the only real question is, what are you reading next? Listen to Black Lit from the Black Effect Podcast Network
他们不想要一大堆像Ella Baker、Michael Max和Martin Luther King那样的小人物到处跑。当你审视许多不同的文化时，他们会说，我们需要知道你来自哪里。考虑到这是黑人阅读月，唯一真正的问题是，你接下来要读什么？在Black Effect播客网络上收听《黑人文学》
on our iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在我们的iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。这是一个IHeart播客，保证是人类制作的。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。